our hall of fame friend uh marshall falk
back here on the rich eisen show on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you marshall
i'm good man i'm good did you hear that
about ben simmons did you hear that yeah
yeah yeah i know you know i just i can't
believe you guys are talking about
practice you know
where were you when that happened you
were on the ramps right when that
practice reign happened like what were
you uh yeah yeah you're on the rams
i was literally in disbelief
it i was just like wow
and i couldn't figure out
i'm like
what's wrong here is
is the fact that we're really talking
about practice or that he thinks that we
shouldn't be talking about brent
well i mean ben simmons i was i'm
serious i was i was listening i remember
i remember that like i was i was with ai
but then i was like
hold on wait but practice is for real
because you need to practice yeah
i know it feels like it was it was it
was an awkward time which i i didn't
know which side to go on i didn't know
should i be on larry brown's side should
i be honest i was i was confused
marshall faulk my buddy right here back
on the rich eisen show okay marshall um
you want to put what derek henry's done
at least in the last five games if not
his entire career into words oh man
and um and i'm and listen i am i am on
record
um i was i'm a guy who when i when i
watched
alabama running back i felt like they
came into the league a little beat up
because of how much they relied on them
so much at alabama and how physical the
fcc can be
and uh and i wonder if if he if if he
had
uh it's not the the the actual speed but
the foot speed
to actually uh
uh navigate when holes are you know you
have to make a cut and quick feed
for a big guy and man he's uh
whatever whatever he didn't have he's
definitely worked on it
his lateral movements is better but
just a just a breakaway speed um i
didn't i didn't and and i remember
because you guys mentioned this i
remember eric dickerson used to not look
like he was running that fast
and it's because they're so big it's
just like they're galloping
uh he he has to say i'm like it doesn't
look like he's running that fast but the
guys who are chasing him
they're going backwards or he's
or he's that fast but
it's unbelievable man you know we
we had him on the show last week
marshall and i asked him what his
his world was like a day after a game
and you know his recovery
appears to be working just as well as
the day of the game or last night the
night of the game because it just looks
like it's effortless which is you know i
i know it definitely is not
he did he looked like when he was
talking to lisa salters last night like
he had just you know strolled through
the park like it did not look like he
was in any way shape or form banged up
hurt
uh gassed he looked like he could go
another quarter if necessary yeah and
and and um and and here's the thing i
i'ma say this and i don't want to be the
old guy talk about you know back in the
day when
you literally had training camp and you
banged
um
i just think about this early in the
season for some of these dbs who
you haven't even hit anybody you got you
got you got six four 250 coming down
healed at you
and nobody's touched him yet
and look i'm i'm a slip like i couldn't
get out of my break too i just
hey listen that's a that's an easy
business decision there
easy
easy i'm turning that one down
but what about his uh preparation i mean
and and what it must take because he is
um
to say he's on pace to obliterate
everything um including that chris
johnson record that you used to hold of
most scrimmage yards in a regular season
we're not even talking about uh an extra
17th game like he's on pace to
obliterate it in the regular 16 games
that you had
marshall yeah so i just
it it's there and here's the thing he he
has a coach he's playing for a coach
who that's that's the mindset
that that is the mindset they that's all
they want to do they just want to they
want to bloody your nose
you know i don't remember if you well
i'm sure you remember yesterday those
first couple of drives the defense
stopping buffalo in the red zone having
them kick two field goals or they would
have got away from the running game
man
it was like after they got those two
stops
and tennessee got the ball
they lined up in old school get under
the quarter get under the center eye
formation
power downhill running and
it just it starts to wear on you i just
i cuz nobody nobody plays like that
anymore
you you cannot prepare for it
and i just always remember marshall
watching games with you at uh at the nfl
network for all those years and
you would be infuriated when you watch
somebody run
successfully two three straight snaps
and then tap their helmet and run off
the field i never see him tap
i never see him tap ever
i'm gonna tell you i i have to he he's
full he he is
um everything you want and his
conditioning
is is is top-notch that's all i want
that's all i look for
um last night
i'm talking after after after a powerful
one uh big big time uh you know break
tackles uh get the yards
back to the huddle
back to the huddle and and i always say
by the time you run off the field and
run back on
that you didn't caught your breath
and and i just i like the way i like the
way he's playing and i like the way that
they play with him and how that's their
identity
as a team
and if they lose they're going to lose
with that identity
do you think last one for you on this
subject matter you think you're gonna
have a niche luncheon with him at one
point and welcome him into the club of
football heaven in canton ohio easily oh
my god rich easily i mean this dude
what what he is doing and and here's
here's the thing there's nothing like
him in the league right now i mean the
closest thing is is if not you air is
over in pittsburgh
it's the closest thing
there's nothing like
him
in football for you to prepare for
like
i'm just thinking about it
think about back in the day when you
didn't have that many scrambling
quarterbacks when you played against vic
you would have a wide receiver go like
pretend to be vic would they do they put
a defensive lineman back there to beat
him
you're right i mean you are so right
there's no scout team in this guy
there's no scouting right like scout
team you got to go get your defensive
end to go
to be very camry yeah
serious
it's it's it's unbelievable telling you
because it's
his size his speed and and his agility
because that's what i thought he didn't
have you know i thought he just did a
lot of falling forward in college but
i mean the footwork his lateral movement
the ability to like run you know have
the connectivity between his eyes and
his feet and he's not slipping he's not
just some big guy getting hit and he's
falling down
marshall faulk pro football hall of
famer a few minutes left with him here
on the rich eisen show so we just
established so much about derek henry
and how impressive he is and how
terrific he has been and i was saying
earlier marshall that this burnishes in
my mind arizona's undefeated resume
because they're the only team that held
him under 60 yards now obviously that
game got out of hand and they did
abandon the running game one would think
to try and keep up with kyler murray and
that offense um
that's my setup and windup to ask you
the best team in the nfc is it the
undefeated uh arizona cardinals or one
of the legion of five and one teams from
dallas
green bay tampa bay and the los angeles
rams who do you have for me on that
front
i i i say if it was any other team
if it was green bay that was undefeated
if it was seattle that was undefeated
um if it was the rams that was
undefeated tampa that was undefeated
dallas that was undefeated we wouldn't
even ask this question and i'ma
apologize to the to the cardinals to the
arizona cardinals for even having to
answer this question but yes
yes and and and just look at how they've
won games
and what they did to the rams and what
they did to the titan you know they they
are winning
games and their defense i know we're
talking about calamari and the receivers
and the running backs but look at what
their defense has done it it's been
impressive
you know what what they've been able to
do
up front and um you know the focus is in
jj
wow
by himself it's not that on the back end
you got buddha baker and they're just
making it they're making a lot of plays
and they're playing good team football
and let's just give them their respect
they are the best team in the league
because they are the only undefeated
team in the league and let's go with
that and colin murray is playing like a
listen he's playing like an
mvp candidate
there's no doubt and i i i will echo
your sentiment in this respect marshall
even though i did ask the question but
you know obviously it's such a
slim margin between winning it all or
winning a division and then not at all
and so on and so forth but um what steve
khan the general manager has done
is he has supplemented the star players
like kyler murray and
uh deandre hopkins with somebody like aj
green a former number one who doesn't
have to be number one j.j watt who
doesn't have to be
number one and also james connor former
you know uh lead running back in
pittsburgh doesn't have to be number one
now zach ertz who was counted on so
heavily in the offense in philadelphia
he's now a supplemental part
and that if everybody stays healthy this
is going to be a team to beat
i would echo those sentiments in that
regard
i i say that they are the team to be and
and it comes down to
and i and i think that you know we saw
the difference we saw the difference
between
um
uh kyla murray and the guy who has all
the commercials
all the commercials
there's a huge difference between those
two quarterbacks huge difference
huge difference baker mayfield and kyla
murray you saw that just a huge
difference between kyle murray is the
reason why you win
and he's the reason why his team is in a
position that he is um
i'm i'm just i'm impressed all right
i'll bite on that baker are you are you
you're down on baker i mean no no i'm
not down on baker baker's point listen
baker's playing hurt baker's doing
everything that that he can do
um i'm just saying you saw the
difference
they're both the both they're both
oklahoma quarterbacks came out of the
same system you saw the difference
they're about the same height
about the same stature have a lot of the
same attributes but one is the reason
why a team can win and the other is is
managing the team
it's just different
and then let's flip to the other
conference to wrap up our conversation
now the ravens are the only five in one
team in the entire um afc
chargers just got boat race there uh
bills just got got on monday night
football the best team in the afc is
which
um man i'm uh i'm gonna go with the
ravens what would i what i saw from them
i i had to um and and here's the thing
lamar jackson is doing this without a
lot of bodies on that team
and then with the game that week
martindale called against
oh my god i mean he he made he made he
made herbert look like a bear
[Laughter]
listen i'm a bobby a bear fan
but what a line
you know it was like wow my god this we
were just talking about this kid for the
mvp he just drove four touchdowns and
just that quick
anymore can do that to you took out one
of the r
took out one of the r's in herbert huh
mm-hmm
oh my gosh
rich listen you you already know that
environment in baltimore it's a tough
environment to go play in let alone
winning
and
listen i don't think i don't think he's
he'd seen that type of environment and
we threw a lot of stuff at it man they
threw so so much at him i think the
first three series uh the charges were
three and out
and it was it was it was over then how
about this one too marshall that since
2018 okay so that's now 18 19 20. it's
three
uh and a third nfl seasons
the most rushing yard since 2018 number
one is derek henry
number two
is zeke number three is nick chubb
number four is dalvin cook number five's
aaron jones and number six is lamar
jackson
and he's now
slicing people up with pre-snap reads
and post snap you know fourth fifth
options like he's really
really honing his craft it seems right
or or how about this rich
it used to be that that quarterback or
that type of quarterback when they got
down
it was over for them
but two weeks ago
like with his arm in the pocket the
comeback
what were they down 13 19.
19. yes
listen
that is
that is danger for this league
and and what i like is
baltimore they understand that he can do
that
but they're not taking him away from the
strong's they they want him to run and
they want him to play and they want him
to do the things that he's going to do
because
hey nfl
these are the quarterbacks that you're
getting you you they're they're not
they're not birthday many many uh peyton
manning and tom brady and if you if you
want to if you want something like that
and you want to go reach about as far as
the giants reach for daniel jones then
you do that
but good luck
good luck
love you marshall [ __ ] love you marshall
falk this is just a hell of a
conversation as always um all right and
cowboys are for real right before i let
you go they're for real big time um
let's see rich let's see
come on now come on now you just don't
want to give irv his due or where does
this one come from
earth can have this dude but herb is
just like me
there's a show called dallas for a
reason
there's gonna be some drama something's
gonna happen
i thought it was like mccarthy not going
for it on fourth one fourth and one
sending zerline out there and then that
created a whole big mess that dak
cleaned up with cd lam in overtime you
know so what other team is dealing with
their head coach holding them back
there's just always something like this
just can't be
like i can't because just be there's
always something man always
go for it tj you want to hop in there
let's just listen no hoskins just gotten
hers and said the jags and we were all
jaguars
their coach might be urban just won
he just won he just came up with a dub
so that was nice
i mean my bad a team that's winning in
their coaches okay there you go very
good
not a team that won
a team that's winning
so at what point will you believe it
when they're actually in the super bowl
is that what you're saying you're you're
not gonna oh no no no no no i just it's
just early it's early rich and i listen
i'm i'm i
there's
when we all know this when the cowboys
are in the mix it's just so much fun
it's fun man let's be honest it is you
know that's just it's fun they're that
type of organization and i just i like
what they've done the young guys on
defense how they're playing
um but i just i just don't want to
anoint them yet like i want to i want
them to kind of just continue to lurk in
the shadows
and then let the cowboys be you know let
the cowboys be the new cowboys
the old cowboys or the very old cowboys
like er erz cowboys so it's
let's just see richard okay
marshall love you let's uh let's talk
offline too uh what's connected all
right guys you take care of yourself
everybody that's a girl right there it's
marshall falk everybody
he turned herbert into a bear
pretty good that is one of the best
lines i've heard hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here